all right bob yes
bob where'd you grow up where are you
from originally originally from brooklyn
new york
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid
uh no i was one of my grandparents what
happened to mom and dad
didn't like each other so mother and dad
took me they divorced
my parents divorced and i uh wound up
with my grandparents
how would you describe your childhood oh
okay nothing going on that was
awful not until i turned 17
and then i went off to vietnam
vietnam was tell me about vietnam
not much fun it was not a good thing
no maybe not a good thing
yeah what uh what did you do after you
came back from vietnam
i lived here i moved right here and then
i
worked on the oil platforms
for most of my life
and uh i've got a daughter and two
grandkids and
i give them my uh retirement
and you've been uh living in the
tenderloin for how long
about two years
but you've been in the bay area since
when well i've lived over there in
north beach probably 16 years
22 years you moved here from and then i
moved over the hill
to the tl okay but you've lived in the
bay area since
40 years 40 years yeah 40. how old are
you now
i'm 70. 70. and uh
there's a lot of drugs here in the
tenderloin is that drugs been part of
your life too
uh not really i stay to myself
you have friends yeah i've got a couple
of them yeah
and you were married once oh yeah yeah
she passed away
about uh five six years ago
i'm sorry
and looking back at your life what to
what regrets do you have
oh i really don't know i really don't
know
i think i've had a fairly decent life
nothing
tragic you know nothing until my wife
died
you'd say you have a you had a pretty
good life yeah i i believe so
yeah yeah
are you religious no i'm not very
religious guy you know
what's what was what's been the best
time of your life
uh the best time of my life
i had a pretty good life i guess when i
got married and stuff would be
about the best time of my life
and what's been the what's been the
roughest time rough thing you went
through when my wife i
got the cancer yeah you know it
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your in your
life
the most important lesson
not really i don't um
probably the lesson i've learned is
pretty much don't
don't trust anybody i hear that a lot
[Music]
that's why i'm so skeptic when you talk
to me first talk to me
yeah it's a strange request from a
stranger
[Music]
do you believe in karma i do you know
you know sure yeah i you know what goes
around comes around
yeah i believe in that for sure
and you've been in love before it sounds
like with your wife
excuse me you've been in love before
before my life well i assume you had oh
you know the high school girlfriend you
know
that kind of thing yeah but
you felt loved as a child yeah yeah your
grandparents oh very much
did you think the fact that your your
real parents were
not so much in your life had an effect
on you
your grandparents did a good job of i
think my grandparents did a very good
job
taking care of me yeah it's great that
they were there for you yeah
and what do you think of this life here
in the tenderloin where it sucks
drugs are so prevalent yeah it just
slaps
it's just evil
what do you think the uh solution of
that problem is
because it destroys so many lives oh god
i'm
i don't know i don't like because i
can't say anything about anybody else
because
i'm a [ __ ] junkie no i can't say
anything about anybody you know
how are you going to fix it or how you
honestly that's
that's a fact you know that's why i stay
pretty much to myself
right because i can't
no
i'd got this this guy here
yeah oh milo you're all right that
uh i got him
by way of his own real owner uh od'd on
[ __ ] uh
uh that's uh fentanyl fentanyl yeah
that's common
what is your drug heroin yeah heroin
heroin seems to be popular here in the
tenderloin right well that's because of
the fentanyl you know it's right
everybody knows a table uh
a lot of guys still do it though
that uh i just they my old school
you know heroin i'm happy with it when
did you first get introduced to heroin
was it vietnam yeah you know i liked it
so much i actually quit
because i knew i knew if i kept telling
you to kill me
you know and then they'd catch it you
know
i'd nod off somewhere in vc and the nda
would catch up and pull my head off
so that's why i didn't mess with it
and
then about three years ago i started
again oh just recently yeah i'm not you
know
me what your thoughts on sending young
men to war
they shouldn't that's all there is to it
the volunteer thing is fine but to draft
them
no no it changed the man's life forever
man
oh definitely definitely
and drugs became like a a good
distraction for those guys right
oh hell yeah
yeah i mean and then the addiction
center
on a crash course yeah they give you a
lot of goddamn
really cool weapons rock and roll a lot
of good drugs
they turned her back to it you know
you think all the things you went
through vietnam losing your wife things
like that
you know the bumps in the road of course
they make you stronger
but yeah i do believe that you know
yeah that pretty much you know
people just realize you know don't mess
with him
no just leave him alone he's
you don't bother anybody they don't
bother you no
you had some good years with your wife
oh yes
yeah we were definitely involved that's
great definitely
yeah she was great for me what was your
name
laurie laurie
how many years were you married
oh 16 years that's great
yep
that's wonderful yeah but i got to get
out of the tl here soon though
because it's really starting to get
bad it's getting real bad yeah it's not
a good lifestyle
you're out there robbing people like you
wouldn't believe
everybody it's a hard environment to be
where everyone is up to no good
that's fact
i very rarely sleep at night why is that
because of it just
robbing you and just all the shenanigans
going on
it gets worse at night of course yeah
not two weeks ago i'm sitting there
and the car pulled up
seven guys got into a gunfight
you know you don't get an environment
like that
yeah nobody needs that yeah no one needs
that no
and that is getting worse it's getting
worse
what do you think of the future for our
country or or even
the planet i think we'll be all right we
just gotta stop messing around
you know we just gotta stop it we just
gotta
get things right
know work at it a little bit instead of
just picking sides and
battling and fighting hell with it
all right bob thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you and marla the best of luck oh
we will
there we go this is my boy all right
yeah you don't have to take me down
anywhere you could just
you know follow me down the stairs it'd
be wonderful yeah i'll do that
okay thank you bob so i don't come here
meatball